were you allowed kind of treats at the
White House could you have junk food and
yeah on the weekends like yeah yeah I
mean on the weekends I mean it was
pretty strict during the week and then
more relaxed on the weekend I could you
have people over could friends come over
and stuff yeah oh yeah
oh I mean the place was filled with her
friends yeah absolutely and and you know
it's true that you know the White House
does like to prepare all the food and
the kids were not always enthusiastic
about the food that they were being
served so they were always trying to
call for pizzas and you can't order a
pizza to the White House I just tell you
sometimes there were exceptions
yeah sub-tab you could go out maybe and
one of the kids could go out maybe and
meet the yeah you would have thought
that you know war had been declared
there's a pizza truck say pizza was
ordered what do we do with that yeah it
we had lots of challenges like it sounds
like a crank call from the pizza
restaurants and pizzas at the White
House thank you very much we're very
busy
[Music]
you